I asked uh Toby my friend and CEO at
Shopify hey uh Toby what are you what
are you paying for a slack and he was
like oh dude don't even get me sorry
it's millions millions a year on
recurring Revenue to use this SAS
service that's a commodity but imagine
if I could go to top and say hey do you
know what that slack Bill instead of you
paying Millions every year what about
you just pay me like $1,000 once so once
is going to have its first product at
the end of this year which is coming up
but is the first one going to be a slack
competitor yeah you could put two and
three together and uh and see maybe this
is where we're going okay so no
announcement now but that would be a
good one I'll be the first customer I'll
tell you that actually Le let's just do
it yes it is and and I would love to
have you and the 700 uh people on this
as the beta tester we'll get you set up
Jason